KASLIN FIELDS: Welcome to
Architecting with Google Cloud.
I'm developer advocate,
Kaslin Fields.
And today, we're
going to explore
the architecture of Apollo with
engineering lead, Adam Zionts.
Welcome, Adam.
ADAM ZIONTS: Thank you.
I'm really happy
to be here, Kaslin.
KASLIN FIELDS: So I
know Apollo provides
an implementation of GraphQL.
Could you first tell us a little
bit about what GraphQL is?
ADAM ZIONTS: Definitely.
GraphQL is an API
technology that
helps developers provide access
to all of their data via graph
interface.
QL actually stands
for query language.
So it's a query language
to get at the data graph.
And so that differs
from the usual kind
of hierarchical pattern
that REST provides.
It's been hugely adopted by
a lot of major companies,
including Walmart,
Expedia, Netflix, Airbnb,
on down the line, and
originally came out of Facebook
to help provide an API
to the social graph.
KASLIN FIELDS: That
makes a lot of sense.
And it sounds like
a lot of businesses
are finding benefits in
this style of querying.
ADAM ZIONTS: Definitely.
I think that some of
the biggest benefits
are just having all of your data
in one place helps to unlock
a lot of things.
First of all, it cuts down
to the amount of redundancy.
Where, if you have
all that data there,
you're not going to end up
recreating the same thing over
and over.
And second of all,
it opens up that data
to people who might want to have
access to it who aren't just
in engineering, people like
product management or sales.
You want people to
get into that data,
understand how it's
being used, who
is looking at it to help
drive the right kinds
of conversations and unlock the
most value for that business.
KASLIN FIELDS: Cool.
So that's a little bit
about what GraphQL is.
So now could you
tell us a little bit
about what Apollo
does with GraphQL
and what services you offer?
ADAM ZIONTS: Absolutely.
Apollo offers kind of the
default implementation
of GraphQL.
So we have an open source
client, an open source server,
a number of tools
besides those that all
help people get
started with GraphQL
and scale it up to
production as well.
So starting to write out web
applications and APIs, move
data from REST, or
even just start out
new projects in GraphQL to
prove out the value of it.
Beyond those kind
of table stakes
of how to even get started
with GraphQL and build,
we've invested a lot
over the past couple
of years in the idea of
Apollo Federation, which
allows distinct teams to run
their own GraphQL services
but then join them together to
provide a single, unified graph
of all of their data.
And so that's also
completely free
open source, Apollo Federation
that helps big businesses scale
GraphQL within multiple teams.
And then we have a SaaS
application that helps you--
also has a free version up
to paid and enterprise--
that helps you understand how
your GraphQL schema is evolving
over time, see who is
using your graph and how,
and help you to
kind of automate out
that build process and
keep those teams in sync
without needing to have a lot
of Slack communication or email
communication that generally
happens between backend
and frontend in order to get
that kind of API work done.
KASLIN FIELDS: So GraphQL
is an open source API.
And Apollo offers
clients and servers,
which are very popular for
use both with open source
and in businesses.
And then you offer all
of these additional tools
to help make using
GraphQL at scale
in large businesses a
lot easier and kind of
make a lot more sense
in the enterprise space,
like DevTools, query
monitoring, this kind of--
I don't know how to
describe it, but like a kind
of an auditing tool, it sounds
like you were describing?
ADAM ZIONTS: Yeah, yeah.
So our mission around
GraphQL is to make
sure that we provide
all of the tools
that businesses need to be able
to scale and manage their graph
in production safely.
KASLIN FIELDS: Awesome.
So Apollo provides a lot
of tools and services
to help developers at
these big companies,
and open source as well,
work with data via GraphQL.
And you're serving a lot
of users and companies.
How does a user typically start
using Apollo's capabilities?
ADAM ZIONTS: Great question.
Typically, users get
started, or companies
get started, using GraphQL
and using Apollo bit by bit.
We very much believe that
the idea of re-architecting
and starting over from
step one via some big
like Flag Day and
years of development
is not something that anyone
is trying to do in 2022.
And we highly
recommend that when
people want to get
started with GraphQL,
started with Apollo,
they do that by one
feature at a time,
one application at a
time, even one page,
one component at a time when
you're talking about React.
And so generally,
that's how people get
started, as this
test case, to say
can we take this maybe
complicated feature
and move it over to a graph?
And then once there's
success in that,
you can incrementally,
iteratively
start adding more and
more into that graph.
KASLIN FIELDS: This sounds
like a lot of use cases
that I see in the Cloud
space, especially.
Whenever a business is adopting
any kind of new technology,
it's always best to start with
maybe one or two applications
that you can start shifting
over to that new technology,
and then shift more and more
as you see the benefits,
and as it makes sense, and
as your engineers develop
the skills to use
those tools, too.
ADAM ZIONTS: Definitely.
And it's very similar
to Kubernetes,
even, and very much where
that idea of Apollo Federation
comes from--
the idea of being able
to move incrementally,
to be able to segment
things off separately,
but then bring them
together in the end.
All of those things are
very prominent in the space
of how to do technology
right, given all the things
that we've learned, and very
much the direction that we
try to come out as Apollo.
KASLIN FIELDS: Awesome.
So a lot of businesses will
start maybe shifting something
over into GraphQL, start
looking at Apollo services,
and maybe start
moving something over.
How does all of this
work on Apollo's side?
And where does
Google Cloud fit in?
ADAM ZIONTS: Yeah, so our
SaaS application that I talked
about before, that helps
track which schemas
are being deployed
over which time,
that helps you to craft
out excellent queries
and mutations, and share
them with your friends
and colleagues, that gives
you insights into who
is using your graph how.
All of that data is hosted
inside of Google Cloud.
And the services
behind the scenes
that help make all
of that possible
is coming from
Google Cloud as well.
We very much believe that our
core competency as a business
should be building
excellent GraphQL
tools that help developers
build excellent apps,
and not learning how
to manage and run
complicated infrastructure.
KASLIN FIELDS: So let's
talk a little bit more
about this architecture.
What are some of the pieces that
go into it, both Google Cloud
products and other
types of technologies
that you use to do what you do?
ADAM ZIONTS: Sure.
So we're running most of this
atop GKE, Google Kubernetes
Engine.
And on top of that, we're using
a number of different databases
and stories behind
the scenes, some
of the things that
we're running ourselves,
for instance Memcached, Kafka,
and an old data source database
called Druid that helps us
manage that time series data.
A lot of things, we also use
Google Cloud for hosting.
For instance, Cloud SQL,
which are using Postgres,
ThinkTable, BigQuery,
Pub/Sub, Spanner
is another really big one
that we rely on as well.
We also have a couple of
services deployed in AWS
as well, so that we can
have multi-Cloud support
for the most critical
aspects of our system.
And I can go into more detail
on any of those things, again.
KASLIN FIELDS: I think there's
a lot of folks out there who
can relate to a lot of those
components of architecture--
hybrid Cloud, using Kubernetes
is, of course, very popular.
And I'm a Kubernetes specialist.
So of course, I point that out.
But one thing in there that
I found really interesting
is that you're running
your own Kafka.
I hear Kafka in a lot of
architectures these days.
So could you talk a
little bit about why
you decided to run
Kafka yourselves,
and how that's
been going for you?
ADAM ZIONTS: Yeah.
So I laugh because it's like,
I wouldn't say a sore subject.
But I certainly
have battle scars.
We've been running Kafka
over the last few years.
And originally, when we
chose to run our own Kafka,
it was because there just
wasn't an offering for it
on Google Cloud.
There wasn't an offering with
GCP via Confluent Cloud either.
So we started running
our own Kafka then.
And we have definitely--
I think we've
reached a point now
where things are pretty stable.
We're not-- like,
knock on wood--
but we're not having any
kinds of crazy outages
or disturbances because
we're running on Kafka.
But we had to learn
a lot of things.
I remember a lot of
sleepless nights,
just banging our heads against
the proverbial wall trying
to figure out what
the heck was going on.
In particular, there
was this one night
where I had to
escalate to the CTO
at the time, who
was on sabbatical,
because these super
blocks inside of the disk
was actually being completely
corrupted because we were going
over 16 terabytes, which
apparently you can't
do on XT four-file system.
Meanwhile, I'm like--
I've been using
Kafka a few months.
I had no idea what was going on.
I felt like I learned much more
in that one night about Kafka
and about disks that I
had in the previous month.
But that being said, not
something I particularly
want to repeat.
So the thing we're actually
looking at right now
is how do we migrate to a Cloud
provider to make sure that now
that the world is kind of caught
up with our usage of Kafka
and there's plenty of
options out there, make sure
that as we grow out
the size of Apollo,
we're not going to have
to have a Kafka team just
to manage that queue.
KASLIN FIELDS: Yeah, that
makes a lot of sense to me.
And I think a lot
of folks out there
can relate to having some
part of our infrastructure
that's just, like, we
have to run it ourselves
because reasons.
But it causes a lot of pain.
Maybe eventually, there
are better options.
And you start
considering moving over
to one of those newer
options so that you
can focus more on
your core business,
rather than these pieces
that you have to run
to make the business work.
ADAM ZIONTS: That's right.
And one thing that
we've also started
to do over the last year or
so has been just investing
more and more in Pub/Sub.
So we haven't added a
lot into our Kafka queue.
That's mostly just
quote-unquote "legacy stuff."
And we're starting to think
about that migration now
for the things that are
in Kafka since they're not
super compatible with
Pub/Sub at the moment.
KASLIN FIELDS: Cool.
So one other thing
I want to point out
about your
architecture is when we
were talking about
all of this, I
found out that you are running
pretty much your whole business
on a single Google
Kubernetes Engine cluster.
And as a Kubernetes
specialist, I
found this very
interesting and exciting.
I'd love to hear more about
how that's going for you,
and some of the tools
and kind of tactics
that you use to make a single
cluster for multiple teams,
multiple products
even, work for you?
ADAM ZIONTS: Yeah.
Another great question,
and probably something that
will evolve as we grow.
Like, all of our
Kubernetes Engine
and the way that we
built our backend
was originally out
of one team, as I'm
sure it is for a lot
of folks who have seen
huge growth in their companies.
And now we have almost a
dozen engineering teams.
We're about to
begin doubling that.
So I'm sure that a
lot of these things
are going to change as we
scale and grow out Apollo.
But ultimately,
being able to have
all of this in one GKE cluster
has been pretty advantageous.
It means that we can wrap all
of our [? kubectl ?] tooling
to all work in one way.
It means that whenever
you're inside of the cluster,
you can access logs from
multiple different services
or do operations on
without needing to log in
and log out, and be like,
am I logged into the right one?
A couple of things that
we have done to make sure
that we don't have
big problems there
is make sure we have separate
namespaces to match production
and staging traffic.
And just make sure to
keep those separate.
And also, just having
different node pools.
Because not every service
has made the same.
So we have a bunch of
different node pools
where we can use taints,
and tolerations, and just
selectors to ensure that
those services can be assigned
to the correct node pools.
Or in cases like Kafka,
that's just on its own.
You don't have a
noisy neighbor problem
where Kafka and some other
thing are all on the same pod
and one is being
starved of resources.
KASLIN FIELDS: I
want to point out
for anyone that's not
familiar with GKE,
we have this concept
of node pools,
where a single node pool
is all virtual machine
instances of the same type,
the same kind of hardware
configuration, the
same pieces there.
So then you can use Kubernetes
taints and tolerations
to manage where your
workloads are run,
making sure that they're
run on the right hardware,
the right machines
for that workload
ADAM ZIONTS: That's right.
And that's a--
I say it's all pretty much good.
Kind of a similar
start to Kafka,
like we have learned our--
we've learned our
lessons the hard way.
For instance, we,
in general, are
OK with having pods from
staging and from production
on the same nodes.
That's not a huge deal.
Could be a little scary.
For instance, one time
we were using local SSDs
to store a whole bunch of state.
And they were just picked
up by the same file path.
And we ended up leaking data
between staging and production,
which had this massive
effect on wiping out
a swath of our database.
This was years ago.
And we didn't affect any
customer traffic because of it.
But it was the most perplexing
issue you could imagine.
And so, definitely,
there is a huge advantage
in keeping things as
separate as possible.
And as I mentioned before, as
we grow out more and more teams,
our goal and the way that we
think about team management
at Apollo, is that
each team should
be able to its own stack of
architecture, top to bottom,
as much as possible, and
do that independently.
So that might mean having a
different namespace or even
entire different
cluster per team,
and being able to enjoy
those things together
across some kind
of [? period. ?]
KASLIN FIELDS: Awesome.
I think as you grow, like
you said, a lot of folks
start out with
technologies that work
when you're one team that's
trying to do a thing.
And then as you start
growing more teams,
there are all these types of
challenges that you encounter.
And so you have to start
thinking about different ways
to do things.
So that makes a lot of sense.
ADAM ZIONTS: Yeah, and for me,
that's part of the fun of this.
I remember starting
off in engineering,
I had this idea of wanting
to do everything perfectly.
And as you get in, months
in, you're like, OK,
it's all about trade-offs.
You're not going to do
the perfect thing ever.
You're going to do the right
thing for the right time.
And six months from
now, that's not going
to be the right thing anymore.
Nothing lasts.
And I don't know,
I find that problem
really fun and
interesting, of balancing
all of those
different priorities,
and making good decisions,
and then fixing the airplane
as you're in the
air, so to speak.
KASLIN FIELDS: Awesome.
So Apollo has a lot of
innovation coming up,
it sounds like.
As you grow up
more teams, you're
going to consider
different ways that you're
going to do your
Kubernetes architecture.
We talked about Kafka possibly
moving into a managed service.
Anything else you want to point
out about ways that Apollo
is kind of innovating,
both on their business
and on their infrastructure
architecture?
ADAM ZIONTS: Yeah.
Those are all really
good examples.
I think that, in general,
as you grow and scale
out the number of teams that
you have, there is a lot-- like,
a lot of people
talk about scale.
And the first thing
that usually comes
to mind for me is like,
what is the TPS that you're
trying to deal with?
How much more traffic
are you getting?
But as I've kind of
gone through my career,
I've started to think much more
of scale in terms of people.
How many people can
you have actively
collaborating on this code
base, on this infrastructure?
And a ton of work
is going to be done
over the next several--
over the next six months,
over the next year,
probably ad infinitum,
to make that more
and more achievable,
like we were talking about
with trade-offs before.
So that means separating
this infrastructure
so that each team can
its own architecture.
That means making it easier
to deploy things and have
the observability that
you want out of the box.
That means starting to
use more managed services
instead of hosting
things ourselves.
We're also dealing with
that other side of scale,
where we have customers
like Walmart, and Netflix,
and Airbnb, on down the
line, more and more,
who are starting to
adopt GraphQL, who
are starting to adopt Apollo.
And being able to lean
in a little bit more
to more events-driven
systems, making sure
that we have partial degradation
rather than complete failures
in places, starting to do
more chaos engineering.
There's a lot of fun
things ahead of us
infrastructure-wise,
to make sure
that we can hit both of
those kinds of scale,
both the scale that comes from
just the raw growth of traffic
as well as the engineers
that we're all collaborating
with now.
KASLIN FIELDS: Awesome.
And speaking of
scale and growth,
I know that GraphQL is
growing in popularity.
Of course, Apollo's
offerings are therefore
getting a boost as well.
So I'm sure a lot
of folks out there
are probably starting
to think about GraphQL
in their businesses,
maybe they're
interested in some of
the features and products
that you mentioned.
Could you tell us where we
can find more about Apollo?
ADAM ZIONTS: Absolutely.
So the best place to start
is just our landing page,
apollographql.com.
We would love for
you to check out
Studio, that SaaS application.
That's at
studio.apollographql.com.
If you want to just learn
GraphQL and get4 started,
we actually have a course
that we're offering, Odyssey.
And that's at
odyssey.apollographql.com.
And last but certainly
not least, we
are doing a ton of hiring.
So if you want to work with us,
you can find that Careers page
on our main website,
apollographql.com/careers.
Or just connect with me
directly on LinkedIn.
KASLIN FIELDS: Awesome.
I love hearing about
learning opportunities, too.
So if you want to check out
any of those awesome things
that Adam just mentioned, be
sure to check out the links
in the description below.
And be sure to
like and subscribe.
Thank you so much for
being on today, Adam,
and telling us about
your architecture
and what Apollo is doing with
GraphQL and Google Cloud.
ADAM ZIONTS: Yeah, thank
you so much, Kaslin.
It was a real pleasure
to be here and get
to share that with you.
And I would be remiss
of me to not shout out
the excellent people behind
the scenes who have built
up all of this infrastructure.
Because I can't claim
very much credit myself,
as I've moved on to the
management side of the world.
So a really huge
shout out to the team
that has made all
of this possible,
that keeps it all
running, that is on-call,
and that is doing all this
work to make improvements.
And come join us.
KASLIN FIELDS: Awesome.
Thank you so much.
ADAM ZIONTS: Thank you, Kaslin.
[MUSIC PLAYING]